[Music]
I go every time
Change clothes in the toilet
Become a train in the opposite direction to the school
I alone jumped out of my usual appearance
and went on a trip
without a destination [Music] A place I had never been to
Why are you here?
No, it's raining. I wonder if I shouldn't take a rest
. There was a lot of elaborate music I wanted to go to. Why didn't I go to Kyoto, Okinawa, or Hokkaido
?  It may fall in the second half, it may explode on the Shinkansen,
it may fall, the meteorite may fall, I'm waiting, why don't you know
[Music]
You see, I'm always like that
When
all the time comes just before,
I've never been stronger What should I do if it doesn't work for the first time
? If I fail, I
'll regret it.
I don't think so, but
I hate it